okay
for people joining this live stream
we are talking about a piece of language
design related to question functions
uh just to give some context here
um
[Music]
let's see should i what is this should i
run this just
because that's a perspective guide page
that we'll want to add for 13 something
like it okay
okay so let's just let me just get
oriented here
okay so we have
a question object which represents
a certain
uh let's see do i need to i need to
update documentation presumably
uh
everything was checked in like last
friday so i'm sure you've done it
i'm gonna do it again anyway
just in case we edit something else
um
okay so just let's just
understand what's going on here so
a question object
is a representation of a question is the
moon made of cream green cheese or
something
yes or no
and
it encodes
what what the right answer is and so on
is that correct that's right
okay
an assessment function is an option for
that
that says
um
you know
like in a geo location or something like
that what counts as the right you know
how how you assess it
it's not an option in the in the
explicit sense
it's what is it it's an argument it's
the second argument to question object
would be an assessment function
but for simple cases you don't even need
it when you get to uh when the
assessment gets complicated you use an
assessment function
so an assessment function
hold on hold on a second this is very
weird my zoom crashed and now
it thinks i'm screen sharing
but i'm not
it looks to me like you are
well but it's frozen because the thing
crashed
uh
let's see
is that well maybe this is better
let's try this
okay it cleared
server must have had some time out
um
okay keep going
um
right so assessment function is an
option it's a symbolic
object that you apply an answer it about
the user's answer to and it says it
gives a result an assessment result
object that's basically saying correct
or incorrect and here's your score
right
okay
is this can i run this this create
notebook
uh lower in the
in that thing there's a demo notebook
that will
you don't have to install a couple
packets but you can do it oh what should
i do i mean
if you want to poke around at it you
should do the demo notebook thing in
here
okay right there at the bottom
what do i need to install can i just
the demo notebook does the backlit
installs
okay so i just run this let's run this
that'll open a new notebook then
there'll be more cells to run
so that top
right
okay
all right so that's installing two
prototype backlits
but we'll let everything work in 12 3.
this most of this stuff will be 13
features so this is a
okay way to let you run it now
what is this now so this is that's a
question object it doesn't have the
latest design but it is it's works
okay so this is
[Music]
so where's the answer
between that last thing between so since
this is a simple one
you can give a test function right there
that is applied to the answer and gives
true or false
but
if in more complicated cases you'd use
an assessment function
okay so if i run this then
i get this
i put that to wherever i put it
i press submit
i haven't bought a gallon of milk in a
long time i'm going to open a corner
that's an expensive yeah
okay okay good well good i'm glad i'm
but
um
fair enough
okay
uh
okay
right and we have updated design from
this it's not implemented but i don't
want to get so what is that
that's the image in the text in a column
or a grid or something i see okay fine
so if i uniconize that
okay
okay fine
okay i get it
okay so let's review again so question
interface did we that was what we
developed last time as i recall that's
right that's right that's that's new we
have
documentation cvs that's futurized to
look at in this meeting if we have time
okay all right okay
so here's a more complicated one
so
select category is a type of question
interface is that correct that's right
and so we have question interface
um
that's a that's a thing for which there
will be documentation for the different
various different question interfaces is
that correct that's right
okay
prompt choices
what's a category
right so let me evaluate this and you'll
see it'll it'll probably make more sense
so this is like sorting or categorizing
matching whatever you want to call it
okay right so you know this is we're
calling it category that's a little bit
weird here but if you were
if it was some thing like you know
tomato on the left and fruit and
vegetable on the right it kind of the
terminology makes more sense
categories
well maybe we shouldn't use something
which is incomprehensible what does
canada
we we've we've cycled what is choices
and categories what is choices and
categories what does that mean so in
this interface choices it's the left
drop down and categorizes the right drop
down
why don't we just call it left
you know
i mean is it always going to be a drop
down uh for select category it can't
well i mean we we could always expand it
with additional options
it's the right name for this i think
this should be called you know match
match drop downs or something
yeah
i mean the select category was
incomprehensible to me
i mean if it's a question of if it was a
fixed thing on the left and you said is
this a fruit vegetable
whatever i don't think that's even a
category thing that this is very obscure
yeah
this is basically
um
match sets or something or match
match
match pair pairing maybe um yeah
right because you're not doing all the
things on the left you're just doing one
of them
okay um in this in this case
well but but match a that that's an
obscure case that you're doing a single
matching one thing on the left with one
i i mean this is a you know it's like
well you can answer whichever question
you want pick a president this is a very
obscure thing right i don't even know
whether this case is interesting but
certainly its name is incomprehensible
okay
the
it's easy certainly easy to change the
names within question interface this the
assessment function where has
the term category
is something that we want to you know
have consistent
that assessment function could go in
multiple interfaces is the idea okay but
then i don't know where the category is
the right name so we need to
okay so let's look at this here and so
that little next
input cell create qa form or authoring
notebook has the prototype it's
a lot of work to do um and we you know
we had the long meeting about ux on the
normal form notebooks yesterday a lot of
that will probably have implications
here
so what what is going to be what is this
one roughly going to look like
so it's like the formula but instead of
inserting things that are like form
objects that they're inserting things
they're like question objects and the
submission action
always has assessment
right and it and the and then it marks
up
the generally it'll mark up the
question objects with checking by the
way this should have a different colored
header or something because otherwise
people are going to register
on on in friday's ux design meeting
we're bringing some initial graphic
design for question object interfaces in
default notebook and the q a for
notebook okay yeah yeah
this is hopefully not the meeting we're
in right now for designing ux here okay
good but but the workflow is important
to discuss so these question objects
their their natural home is in these q a
form notebooks that's where they do the
best stuff
you can certainly use them anywhere but
this is where they're interested so what
i what i start off with is
my big test
and then i say you know
uh
who
invented the bicycle or whatever
typically the prompt is going to be in
the question object
so why is that
um i i mean i think that the idea is
that you have these question objects are
sort of modular and you can okay fine
well that's fine okay fine so all right
so then that's certainly putting
something in there like factoring
quadratics right yeah
whatever
history bicycle history questions
yeah um
okay so then that goes in a question
object
which is created from the insert gui
basically correct
okay
and and why is it
that this can't just be in a standard
form notebook
why does this need a different kind of
form notebook
well this submission
is much different yeah there's
there's no dealing with custom
submission or submission actions at all
in q a from notebooks it's all about the
assessment
it's all so walk me through that for a
second so i mean i fill out the
questions and then i peel off the thing
that's actually going to be the test
that somebody's going to do right who is
that by the way it's bob barker former
host of the press is right
where they always ask people what you
know what normal things cost
oh okay fine that was the game show
um
okay
uh
okay so
um
so i'm sorry so then you fill this out
this is the
kind of this the that turns into a
specific copy of the quiz to be used by
students or whatever exactly you cloud
deploy it you email it around whatever
you want and then students can take it
okay and then but but that has
umbilically connected itself to wherever
the answers are going to go is that
correct right right
so what we want people to do is
deploy like in the settings when you
hear this a choice to deploy the like a
collection of apis essentially that
serves as the as the
back end of these things
right you can create one of these
notebooks and run it locally and it'll
store the assessments in the notebook
and then you could upload it back to the
teacher but that's
not a great workflow what we really want
people to do is do the assessment in
cloud
um
where where it basically deploys an
external bundle with an assessment
endpoint and
several other endpoints
for both the student and the teacher
that okay
so
you create this thing this notebook
is so for example
if you were
a
fourth party fifth party who knows we've
got a lot of parties here
where you are
a you know professor makes quiz
professor licenses quiz to publishing
company
publishing company
sells quiz to another entity
okay
so then that means that that that quiz
which was created by professor one
and connected to you know to her
uh
you know
cloud account
right
no well the authoring notebook is not
in that case you're passing around the
authoring notebook and it's not
connecting your clown account until you
oh no but assume that you that you if
you've already generated then that
scenario isn't working you need to pass
around the authoring notebook and that's
right but that's what i'm saying i'm
saying i'm saying
post look it's like source code versus
you know generated stuff let's say that
they want to pass around let's say that
they've got multiple sections of their
whatever it is and that the grading
should go to different people and
they're not going to pass around the
source notebook they're going to part
they would like to pass around a built
notebook but the built notebook already
has burnt into it it's destinations
correct correct
okay so there's an issue with that
perhaps i don't know i mean i don't know
whether the
um
i mean all we tell people just pass
around the source
but but so the idea is as soon as you
have built it
to make a shiny quiz that you can give
to people it has also burnt in the
callback basically right i mean and we
could make a utility for changing that
because
it's all one cloud deployment
generally no we couldn't but think about
it no we could well it depends on what
what kind of utility because the source
is the only place it's at the level of
the source okay the source still has the
assessment information in it
by the time it's deployed the assessment
information is hidden behind it the tool
would have to copy the whole cloud
object as well as change it in the
source yeah
so there'd be permissions to handle and
that sort of thing right so let's assume
right now as our as our boundary
tradition right now
that people pass around the source if
they want to pass this around
and we'll worry about the other case
later right right so teachers pass the
source to teachers teachers passions
can we get it written down
what the outline workflow is for this as
what will eventually be a workflow piece
of workflow documentation
so as i understand it
right what you're doing what you're
telling me is you you have a q a form
notebook
you
fill out the questions and the
assessments in the q a form notebook you
deploy the q a form notebook saying
and and you get
you get two things from that
you get
this is the actual notebook you can pass
around to people
presumably it can be deployed either on
desktop or cloud
you can pass it around to them or maybe
what we do given that it's all all of a
cloud it's all cloudy
that what we do is we maybe this is what
you've done
that deployment
causes you to get a cloud object that
represents
the quiz to give to students so we
haven't done that we haven't done that
automatically yet but it makes sense
right but so then what you deliver to
people is
essentially a
a manifest of here are the assets that
you have right so this was your source
here's a link to your source
um
you know
you may as well upload the source to the
cloud it seems to me
by default and then what you can give
people is a manifest here's your source
you give to somebody else if you want to
here's the built for for test takers so
to speak
version
and here are links to the back end that
allows you to see what got submitted and
all those kinds of things right
okay so then this becomes so what you're
effectively doing then
is
you author the q a notebook
but then what comes back from that
is
a cloud object
when you deploy that you get back a
cloud object which itself points to
multiple cloud objects that are the
various stages of using the thing right
and the app right and all of that
information should be recoverable from
the cloud object
so the important thing is to keep track
of the cloud object which cloud object
the
the one that this hosts a bundle of apis
and storage scores well i understand it
but what i'm suggesting is that that
this which you could author on the
desktop you deploy it you get a single
cloud object back that cloud object is
itself a notebook
that
describes what the other cloud objects
are
oh
like an index.nbc yes basically
right so yeah so that's reasonable yeah
so that way when you have that thing
it's like that's my
you know geometry test thingy yeah and
then what you do is
then you can store you know you know you
put them in a directory in the cloud
and you store them there and that's
where you're keeping them
and um
then
as soon as you want to make use of one
you can either
download its source from that manifest
edit it make the next year's version
or you can just use that
student thing now i think the thing
we're going to want
is let's say you give this test once you
get a bunch of students
you we're going to want something where
it's a different section of students or
something that are going to do that test
right so in other words you don't want
whatever the back end is
that accumulates results right we have a
clear api on it that would that would
wipe it out and reset it
which we don't want that you want to
keep you want to archive things no we
just want something where look what i
think should happen is you definitely
want to archive things a lot of teachers
would just get their scores once you
know put them in their lms and start
over
whatever yeah
that's a mistake and then one day that
we'll we'll get this phone call from
them oh my gosh i did all these students
filled out all this stuff and i lost
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah it makes
sense it makes sense the archiving makes
sense
okay all right
okay so then
this this um sorry this design that you
just described to this cloud object that
um refers to a bunch of other cloud
objects does does that intersect pretty
closely with this cloud service objects
design that you also
i don't know which cloud service objects
design
bob the cloud service deploy yeah yeah
yeah it's basically
that it's similar yes it is similar to
that right okay okay i just wanted to
make sure that i i mean and he's
describing an index page in that bundle
that we upload which makes sense we
hadn't really ever thought much about
what happens when you visit that page
and it definitely makes sense to have a
piece right and so maybe the return from
the deployment is an association with
those urls yeah i mean that's what it is
but it's usually behind a button right
you hit generate and you never yeah
right
back okay so maybe what the two things
you might get back you might get back a
pure single link
or you might get back the essentially
scraped version of the manifest page
right so what you could get is something
that says
um
where you could get back an association
where one entry in the association is
the manifest page and the other entries
are the individual things that appear on
the manifest page
do we have a place where we would show
that right now or do we just give them
back the built notebook
do we put a doc cell right now we've
been authoring one
sorry can you repeat the question do we
like put a result stripe in the
authoring notebook that would show
no we we don't do that but we could
right well but you might like to show
that when you're using the buttons yeah
i don't have an output cell
right fine but i mean then then the
primary
uh
you know the primary
sort of result
from build it
is the built notebook
but then all these other things like
where your apis are and all that kind of
stuff you have to point to that as well
i i personally think
that
a better strategy would be
to return the manifest page
not return the built notebook and the
built notebook is a click from the
manifest page
if they're all in the cloud
yeah i mean i mean i don't know what
when you say return you mean pop up in a
dialog no i mean i mean use no i cell
there's no output cell to return
something into oh i see what you're
saying and the case where it's done with
buttons in case there's some buttons
which is going to be the
okay then pop the manifest notebook
somewhere
but actually show the manifest notebook
you can show
i don't know why yeah we can make we
could we're opening a notebook instead
of it being the generated notebook it
can be something nice with a button that
opens the generated notebook i think
that would be great that goes other yeah
that probably makes sense but then then
the thing you open there is a desktop
notebook that points to a bunch of cloud
objects but presumably also has a
a mirror of itself in the cloud
right it's it's very it's very similar
to the index page right but in what
in what directory has it put itself in
your cloud account well if you click on
access and cloud it asks you where to
put it
i see and if you don't it's just an
anonymous uuid which isn't great but
there's not a better
thing
it's like the publish dialogue sort of
fine
okay
okay okay all right
so
independently is misspelled come on guys
it's probably me i misspelled that word
90 percent of the time i read it okay
that's one of the problems once you once
misspelled a word yeah yes yeah post
forever
okay so now
okay so this is generating
a question object with a question
interface
okay
okay
so so this is our hook to support things
like question pools or adaptive quizzes
things like that is this is our concept
here where
it's a question a question generator and
the first argument is a function
that returns a question object
and then the and then you have to set up
triggering so the second argument
we have a very murky design but
basically it would tell it when
to trigger
and if you're just using it in a normal
yeah so if you're just using a normal
notebook it'll trigger when you apply
values to it like a show below and and
those value if you put an association in
there with jen where i've opened clothes
if you've been an association the values
will be passed to the function itself
but in a q a form notebook
what we can do is have fancy stuff like
after they answer question four
generate questions five through seven
right they'd all be triggered based on
the user has answered question four and
the values that are passed to them would
have automatic things
which most importantly would be the
assessment result objects for everything
that they've answered so far in the quiz
so you can so the
the question
object that is output could depend on
you know okay hold on
i'm pretty confused yeah okay so then
what's what's going on you're describing
normally in a q a form notebook there
are specific question objects that are
just like
you know
that when the q a form notebook is built
this question object statically
says here's what i am exactly is that
correct now what happens
if one of those
things
depends on
you know
like something like you know who is the
vice president right now
right and that's something where we'd
have to do a look up to find the answer
right so i mean the assessment function
can certainly use the entity framework
without
any issue
okay what about if the question depends
on what about if the statement of the
question depends on
uh
is then you're going to use question
generator
okay so
then you'd have to use something
different
right so in other words the the q a form
notebook by default deals with
statically stated questions
correct i think that's right okay so do
you want to correct that sylvia or
steven schroeder no yeah they're just
yep it's those questions just sitting in
there okay fine okay so it its primary
mission is
statically stated questions
right were you to want a dynamically
stated question
you would use question generator that's
yes that's the proposal here okay fine
i'm not sure it's necessarily the right
name but but i understand the point so
then what a question generator is
is essentially a delayed question in
some sense exactly that's exactly right
okay
if delay if the simple delayed weren't
so intimately tied to cloud deployments
we could maybe get away with using that
around question object but why is it
what works relative cloud of deployments
there's there's second arguments there's
oh cash persistence there's all this
stuff that just doesn't make sense here
right okay but there's
um set delayed uh who knows okay so okay
so then but then the point that you're
making here is that
in the
generator in addition to the state of
the world
that it can pull in dynamically at the
time of generating the question it also
can pull in
the history of that student's
activities
right
correct correct
you know one of them like what time what
time did they start what time did they
answer the last question you know all
these things that right so it can test
it can pull in basically whatever it is
that you would get
from the full
result the full
sort of thing from this quiz being taken
whatever incremental version of that
exists at the time when this is asked
for it gets fed right assessment result
object is the the symbol that
represents that okay so then then just
to understand at the end of the quiz
the assessment result object you get
back is identical to the assessment
result object you would feed into a
question generator were you to
use the question generator at the moment
just before you finish the quiz
that sounds right
i'll let silvia shorter correct me if
there's some detail it's not true about
that
it's just
that's exactly right okay all right fine
um okay
all right so now
okay i think i get it that makes sense
um
the interface
don't don't worry about a fancy gui
interface to this question generator
thing in the q a form notebook
you know that's an advanced feature
right okay i mean just let them write
code
right certainly for the first argument
maybe something for the triggering i
think the triggering might be nice to
have what is what is triggering again
so when when should the
question generator generate and turn
into a question object when the student
opens the notebook after the previous
question after some other question was
answered at 2pm on tuesday when should
when what does it look like when it
hasn't i mean so so wait a minute you've
got a quantum quiz
yeah right you've got a quiz that shows
up
and certain features of it are not yet
measured
and so what does it look like for
question seven question seven is the
superposition of states somehow is that
what you're telling me
uh
sure not that like quantum physics yes
yeah i mean yeah so it's it's you know
it's like a delayed object
no but i understand that but i'm asking
in the actual thing
student gets the quiz
the quiz has 18 questions in it
okay question 15
is not yet known what it is because that
will depend on what else was in this
example we brought this up very briefly
with jeremy davis the other day and he
suggested something similar to to a
slideshow so it essentially just goes to
like the next slide well yeah i mean
there's there's there's sort of two ways
we could either have the whole notebook
kind of do paging or we could just
append things on the bottom yeah it
would have enough squares well
i mean the case
the kind of it hasn't been generated yet
case
it's almost like if you were to see the
whole thing there would be a great big
gray area there right so i didn't want
to worry about what that looked like
right i mean you see what we have above
with your output 22 in just a normal
notebook i figured we could have some
sort of like gear made out of question
marks would look cool but in the q a in
the built q a form notebook i think it
should just be invisible
i think that will be super confusing to
people i'm like okay imagine the
following scenario i think if the button
says on the previous question says
continue instead of submit then it makes
sense
immediately
[Music]
okay i worry about the following
scenario
a student who is a brilliant test taker
opens the quiz there are 11 questions
student says i know exactly how to pace
myself for 11 questions oops they get to
question 10 three more questions pop up
upset that's a good point but i i do
agree with
bob that if it said continue or if there
were some indication of the total number
of questions
we could which may be variable because
it might actually generate more
questions some of the arrays
yeah right so
i think it needs to have some indication
and i have no idea what these things
look like
and go ahead well
even if if it's generating an unknown
number of things then showing it doesn't
solve that problem
well it does if it indicates that
there's that this is an ungenerated
you know marsh of questions or something
right right and even even on the guide
page we have a very futurized cell
called question generate while
that is our solution for
potentially generating many questions
you know okay hold on hold on hold on
hold on
that's not for
right but so
i think that the case
you know we don't know what it is yet
case
if it's a continue continue continue the
infinite slide show so to speak
that's
kind of funny you know
but
it really depends on use cases and it
depends on
um
i mean look i can imagine this being
used
well this is an assessment based thing
right so this is not going to be used
for like
you know this type of technology
might be relevant and we tried to make
it with ask function
for like you know medical uh diagnosis
stuff you know right do you have this
problem do you have that problem well if
you have that problem then we want to
ask you this and listen this
okay but i don't think this is relevant
to that because this has the notion of
this is very much like test the human
type thing
right as in assessment functions and so
on where they are
you know
right rather than building up state
which is what ask function is about
right am i making sense but i think it'd
be good to try and unify those ideas
well that incremental assessment result
object is also building up state
right
um
ethanol livestream is asking about some
type of assignment
that involves running code i have no
idea no idea
i have no idea this is uh
uh
don't know
um
somebody can look at that
i think
uh
if this is something about computer
security and and um
i have no idea
um
i mean this is this is not meta meta
you know i don't know what it is if
you're if you're if your quiz is about
your computer that's never mind i'm not
even going to think about it but okay
let's come back to this thing about when
does
when is the question generator so
essentially what this is
is this is a delay until some action
something happens right yes and and what
you know
we have a notion of cloud deploy of
delayed blah blah blah
right but that delayed
has only one event that causes it to be
triggered
okay the event that causes it to be
triggered is is merely
the um
uh
an http request
yes right
but what this is saying is
you could do a bank triggering
of all these questions or you could
trigger them
uh at the moment where they're being
asked for so to speak right
ethan is asking the reasonable question
how would we recreate
challenges.wilson.com using this
framework
right that makes sense so in the
assessment function we have these
equivalence types that
we
want one of those
fairly soon to be
code
that will happen to the code equivalence
that will from challenges uses or
something very similar to it
so that yeah that's definitely
one of the one of the things we're going
for
right so
that would do that
because suggesting integration with
kaggle i don't know exactly how the
whole framework works or even
whatever the
um
all right so what do we i i
i am going to run out of time here in
just a few minutes but
what is our um
uh
what else can we look at here quickly
i mean you want me to look at
documentation pages here
right if you want to look at the
question interface or question generate
documentation page no what about
question this question object have we
done question object was in twelve three
there are updates in cvs up for
um okay so let's look at question
interface
right oh my gosh i don't know if we'll
finish it all in
the time we have yeah
wow
so you know these names represent maybe
a solid hour of thinking um so they're
not nothing but they're certainly
we're certainly open to changing
okay so let me just understand what this
thing basically does
so
given type and settings what the heck is
this so this is wrapped around a
question object is that correct no this
is the first argument to question object
like oh like so this is like a form this
is like a form object is that right like
a forum
which we don't call a form interface
object
question object
um
so this is the analog okay so this is
defining when the question is going to
be displayed how will it be displayed
right
and there is a default presumably for a
given question type
for a growing question object where the
question object
has
a lot of times the
everything this you don't need to put
this in it's all inferred from the
assessment function
okay
okay
all right so then
then this is the ui now to understand
something every ui we have here
is it obtainable in a disembodied form
through some
other
interface i mean because people you know
this is one of these things where it's
like people use data set just to format
data
even independent of all its other things
because it has some convenient feature
are these you know
this kind of user interface mechanism is
something i can imagine people wanting
completely independent of you know like
that pairing interface thing
it's like well i just might want that
pairing interface period
without
you know all of the tentacles of
assessment and all this kind of thing
right you can you can have a question
object without an assessment function
that's just kind of like a survey
right if you don't have an assessment
right but my question is are these in
fact more general ui elements
i suppose i mean you could we could make
it so that you don't need to just wrap
the thingy question object if that says
anything but you don't need ever prompt
you can say prompt goes to none well i
understand that but i mean
yeah the code is there if we want to
have a design for
well my question is getting out of the
interface
too
you know radio button okay so this is a
layer higher certainly a layer higher
than control types and a specific thing
this is this is an interface
for answering a type of question
it's not a pure is anybody from the
front end team looked at this
uh i'd like to know the answer too who
did who did we have in that meeting a
while ago yeah
lou is there lou okay so i mean my
question to these guys is
if we were to invent
a higher level named
not quite control type but interface
type
that could be one of these things
disembodied to just be used as an
interface
right so we have control types like
radio buttons
and things maybe this is a higher level
version of that that is an interface
type
that's just in a thing called i don't
know interface or something with a
name does that make any sense
i just hate to build something here that
is you know only
you know
sorry this is only available you know
you can you can buy this special kind of
cookie but it's only available if you
buy this boxed set of other cookies
yeah i totally mean i totally understand
what you're saying yeah okay yeah we'll
bring that back to them
okay
um
ethan is commenting an interesting
comment
uh that an application of this would be
uh getting human labels for machine
learning training data sets
that's an interesting thought
can this be used for that
i don't see why it shouldn't be it's a
good use case
so in other words you generate
a you know you're generating a quiz
basically and the quiz says
is this a fire hydrant or whatever right
yeah
yeah i don't
think we're competing with google's
capture system
in terms of number of users but yeah it
could it could do you could use it well
they're more interesting cases for that
yeah so a question for that would be
um
our curation team has certainly done
many tasks like that
i wonder if there's anything we know
because we certainly generate curation
grids
from data
see what i'm saying
and i don't know what i mean i think
it's a little bit of a different case
because
the
you know what we tend to generate
is these giant grids
where somebody's going to spend
you know it's like is every one of these
pictures a tiger
and um
i mean those things have been pretty
well optimized over the years
for our curation team um but it's a good
intro it's an interesting question
um
okay ethan is asking do you have an
annotate this image question interface
uh
we have text completion is on this list
it's not implemented i think that's
on
uh steven schroeder's
very soon short list but you the prompt
could be an image and text completion
right but the other question is is there
a thing where you get to put a bounding
box in an image and we definitely do
have things like geo location oh
yeah yeah i mean there's definitely uh
we're going to expand the number of sort
of clickable no but i think this is an
interesting use case that we haven't
really thought about right i mean one of
our you know cbm's interfaces are
definitely a design point for us to try
to hit moving forward no i understand
but that's for that's for
you know
that's for assess the humans as opposed
to
learn from the humans it's it's
answering the question did the human
learn as opposed to what can we learn
from the human right just my point of
like drawing on
drawing on
graphical interfaces is right is
something that we want to support
right fair enough
um i believe let me just check my
schedule here
yeah i really need to go in a in a very
short moment here
um
okay so we're thinking about making
question interface more generally and we
should move keep moving ahead on a
question generator it seems reasonable
even if i think so when you revisit the
name
yes okay um and i think this should have
another meeting soon okay yes of course
i
agree okay
um
all right and and thank you to ethan on
the live stream for this comment about
machine learning it's a good suggestion
and and please
can somebody
uh show this to alan and uh maybe
uh johan or at least uh
to get input on how this relates to what
we already have for curation interfaces
okay
in other words is this is this relevant
to
um
[Music]
the basic question is is this relevant
to data cleaning and curation
can this be used for that
because we have i mean there's a whole
different project that i hadn't
internalized that it's related
is
making our curation tools that we've
developed over the last 15 years or
whatever
more
you know product production more
prioritized
okay right and that that involves
um
right nick is commenting
uh do we support all kinds of captures
amusing i don't really know what those
are these days
um
i mean yeah that that's a good that's a
good kind of concept
for
i think some of them are a bit bit
irrelevant to us here maybe
um but it's a good concept for what the
challenge response
you know thing looks like
all right let's let's wrap up for now
here and uh to be continued another time
yeah
okay